[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'arrive la tuque à multaq qui fait
barbe il a tu avais tu n'as pas trouvé
il ne l'a jamais aussi bon que dans bull
mais il est formidable il est vachement
bien
c'est une équipe et jusqu'en bas là mais
il est complètement d'accalmie qu'est-ce
qui m'a erreurs dans sa chronique ce
soir que vit dans l'univers des planètes
et pmp quel est le programme du soir
[Musique]
toute la ville
[Applaudissements]
à
ont consacré 24 à celle ci s'est passé à
la télé très très très très vite puis
c'est le principe c'est parfois on y va
c'est parti à l'hôtel une remarque d'un
concurrent sur l'âge des proprios mon
avis sont partis pour payer le double en
vous avez échappé une légère différence
d'âge et
combien décor 19 ans je redis que des
chiffres et des lettres à perte en eau
taillefine petit retard sur le tee shirt
de lolo romejko l'eau le prend mal
l'autre assume plus du tout une brigade
mais j'avais un t-shirt aussi est
marquée grand et intelligent j'ai arrêté
de le mettre
ariel mieux pourquoi en enchaîner sur la
ligne du rer c le poteau maxime guen il
a bien galéré aujourd'hui à fournir aux
studios pour s'occuper il a tout donné
dans sa deuxième passion la passe très
bien maxime c'est bien c'est qu'il a
vraiment tous les talents il ya deux
jours et aussi emmanuel macron scénarii
t du 13 heures de jean pierre pernaut
dans une salle de classe dans l'orne
on appuie nos et donc n'a pu noter que
dès que le président voulait parler d'un
sujet jpp était toujours à la bourre à
si vous leur en parler plus tard tous
les enfants en cm2 sachez bien lire
écrire compter et bien ce qu'on
reparlera tout à l'heure de l'école
qu'ils soient en forme at il été se
sentira tout à l'heure avec les impôts
qu'il appelle alors à tous alors avec
d'investissement d'enfin bravo un
instant il avait jamais eu l'honneur
d'accueillir isabelle morini-bosc du
groupe m6 elle est aussi plus de soirée
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes très bien derrière l'objectif
également les deux là quand je vois à
côté ça fait quand même flipper les
vallées de laon mais j'ai rien de changé
oui c'est pas les pas des idées derrière
la barre n avoir jamais christine vous
en pleine forme et regarder tomber votre
tête droite
non à droite voilà il est con et votent
à gauche mais le csa voilà tu cesses
arrivée d'étape comme ça c'est ça un
joker
allez merci oui mais vidi vici ça veut
dire j'ai maté défunt les chaînes info
je crois j'ai pris des nouvelles de
notre premier ministre edouard philippe
alors 8 en asie dans les locaux de la
république en marche mais un petit peu
aller voir ce qui se passait dans le
mouvement alors les gens lui présente
des militants qui connaît forcément pas
vraiment en revanche les militantes
il en connaît une sur deux